hey guys what's up this is andrew for
sentences.com so sorry i didn't write
anything for some time i was actually
very busy at preparing my training
environment for the live training we are
going to start on discord in september
and i was also busy at preparing my
second master class that is going to be
about technical analysis for beginners
with a focus on how to draw trend lines
and how to make money with it but we're
going to see this later today i'm back
to make a huge analysis on amc so let's
get into it
[Music]
hi guys so once again very very sorry i
didn't post anything for one week but
once again i have a free area on my
discord where i post every day uh some
recaps about amc so i'm just showing you
quickly how it looks so this is my
discord and i have a free area here so
today i post already every day i post
some analysis for example yesterday i
said put back after breakup that nothing
alarming here at all and i'm posting
comments and i try to give you the best
content i can in this channel
so
just for those who miss my analysis you
can find it for free on my discord but
here today i want to dig a bit more with
you into this press action and see what
we have so i'm going to sum up the
situation for the past week i'm going to
remind you what i was saying in my last
video i'm going to give you again my
targets and the levels we need to trade
a goal for those targets to come closer
let's take a step back first
bam
okay so here we go once again
the situation here is that we have one
we have a two here i don't know if there
is a one two or not if there is if this
counts as a one two
then we're going to have
two fifth waves okay here the first that
is going to finish this cycle and then
four and five again to finish the bigger
cycle so i'm not sure but what i really
believe is that there is at least one
fifth wave to come okay so in the
conservative scenario one two three four
and five okay
then to know when this fifth wave is
going to come we need to find some
reversal signs this breakout like i was
saying guys on my discord and for the
past weeks i was waiting for this
breakout so once again i remind you we
had a big fake out here
okay it was this one
but the situation was a bit different
now we have the bullish divergence of
the macd with us that we didn't have at
this time okay you can see that here the
magnitude was going lower that's why
it's very good to have a look at those
dive lenses here you can see during this
breakout the macd here so here the
market is making lower lows and the macd
as well here the market is making lower
lows but the maldi is making higher lows
right this is bullish divergence so we
have this bullish divergence that is
going to impact the price action until
the 25th of august roughly early
september okay this is
my experience that is telling me that
those divergence they have usually an
impact on the price action during the
period between the lows you are
considering or the highs if you take
bearish divergence so here we have this
bullish divergence with us and most
importantly we have the breakout okay
guys so like i said this morning on my
discord this is a text book situation
and i was commenting on this every day
so basically
let's keep this we have the breakout so
first we need to identify the trend so
here quite clearly one two three not
perfect and then here breakout the only
thing that i'm missing here is the
volume we still don't have those strong
volumes
so
i hope they will come soon because they
are very important for this breakout to
be really valid
because when you have strong volumes on
the breakout level it means that there
were a lot of bears at this level and
that if the price goes higher with high
volumes it means that all of these bears
have been eliminated they will not come
back right away because they lost money
and they're uh you know they'll just
step back
and retreat to the higher resistance
levels here we miss those volumes so it
means that those belts they have
retreated before and they're still there
ready to shoot you know kind of so
the battle needs to come again so for
now this is a very nice first battle but
definitely they didn't put all their
ammunition in here so i'm waiting for
this big volume a day where we're gonna
take back some uh nice levels for
example 38 40 46 okay
now
why is it the textbook situation because
as you can see we have the strength line
quite clean we have the breakout after
breakout we have uh you know the market
is pushing higher going to the next
resistance level 38 like i said you know
i give you here for example on my
discord every day the resistance level
38 41 so this was on the 18th of august
17th of august we're already have to the
eighth you know to the atmosphere as
well so 38 is a resistance that we know
for some time and we got rejected here
which is totally fine and we have the
re-test that is you know happening
almost every time whenever you have a
breakout with low volume because it
means that the bears are still there and
you know if the battle was not worn uh
during the breakout then of course
they're gonna try to push the price
lower so this was kind of expected and
as you can see here we had the perfect
reaction yesterday right on friday's
training session exactly on the breakout
trend line which is very positive and we
almost have a bullish and girl thing so
the open here is at
32.72 and the close
32.72 so this is a bullish industry
because open equal to close of the
previous candle and we close higher so
this is a valid bullish engulfing so
this is a perfect situation guys so
now what should happen is that we should
push higher and you use both the
breakout impact and the bullish
divergence impact that we still have
with us
so here to confirm so this is of course
my preferred scenario is that we push
higher and we revisit the 40 and the 46
area this week for this to be confirmed
we can always zoom in okay we go on the
hourly time frame and we apply the same
method so we need to have a breakout of
this line now okay guys
and you can see that we are right on it
and we are also on the 35 resistance
level so here we have a double
resistance so if this breaks right away
on monday morning this looks very very
very good because here we have this long
consolidation period guys for how long
have we been training around 35 it's
been one month right one month we are
around this level okay we are here
basically higher lower higher low around
this level so this makes this situation
really really nice for some strong moves
up so now let's discuss a bit the target
that we have so
once again the first thing is that you
need to draw your trend lines as good as
you can so that you know where are the
resistance levels so exactly this is
what i'm gonna explain in this master
class where i'm gonna basically show you
so there's gonna be two three hours of
uh theory with slides something that i
prepared it took me like around 50 hours
to prepare all of this but i think it's
very helpful especially for beginners
and i explained exactly how to draw
those lines and i'm showing you some
real life examples where i applied this
method on the market and show you how to
set up your trades so here the first
thing i would do is that you need to
replace your trend line okay slightly so
it's 38.7 now because the most recent
past is the most important so here we
have one here okay so now our trend
lines are well
uh positioned this one should be
slightly lower as you can see so that we
match here we match here okay so 34.5
okay so this is actually the level
so this is the first thing i wanted to
show you and now
second thing let's discuss targets as
usual guys for targets i'm using some
more advanced tools which is fibonacci
projections but they gave us very good
results on amc during this wave and this
wave so it's fair to assume they're
still going to give us good results so
we apply so either we consider the one
three from here
okay so one plus three and we put it to
the bottom of the fourth and we have the
one point six one eight so this gives us
a target of hundred and twenty three all
right it can also be ninety three
because it can be one to one or 1.618 so
it depends how strong is going to be
this kicks wave but i believe that it's
going to be very strong uh once we start
to develop higher with strong momentum
because of all the shots that are in
this market so this gives us our target
and yeah like i said uh there's gonna be
many battles that we need to overcome we
need to see stronger volumes this is the
only thing that i'm missing here
uh and i want to see those three levels
not breaking this week if we do it will
really really look very good for this
target to be reached so that's it for me
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget to click
on the like and bell button so you're
gonna be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore see
you guys